What comes to your mind when you think of Australia?
Kangaroos and koalas?
There is one more thing, which is a wonder of nature.
Formerly known as Ayers Rock, Uluru is a natural icon that most people connect with Australia.
Like other famous landmarks such as the Great Pyramid in Egypt,...
...it is placed on a major planetary grid point, which makes it so mysterious.
Uluru is a huge magnetic monolith in the heart of Australia.
This is a sacred part of the aboriginal creation mythology.
That is why the local community wanted to forbid climbing the rock...
...because they believe the path crosses a sacred dream line.
However, if you have the guts to try climbing there, it is possible to do so,...
...but remember that each year several tourists die, mostly from heart failure.
If you are not in the mood of climbing there,...
...just watch how the color of Uluru changes according to the light.